[Music]
hello like hi I'm Jessica day early cha
and I'm a developer advocate for actions
on Google welcome I'm really excited
that you're all here especially because
at the end of a long day so thank you
for trucking along and keeping it going
so hopefully I have enough energy
if you don't defeat off/on and then
what's nice is after this we go to happy
hour so we'll have a good time there
yeah so um just in case just make sure
everyone knows they're in the right spot
this is the intro to building service
apps for Google home and Google
assistance so for you did not or my
interest in this um don't worry you
could sneak out that's okay by me okay
so before we really start and dive into
how to build let's talk about a little
bit of the user perspective and let's
just ground ourselves there first and so
I really want to start off with there's
a shift that's going on right now in
regards to how users are interacting
with technology and this happens every
couple of years for the sake of this
talk we just said every 10 years or so
there's a major shift what the last
major shifts have been when we went
mobile first and I remember being in
college and having my flip phone and not
understanding why would I want to have
an internet on my phone that just seems
really weird and strange now in 2018
it's like oh my gosh of course I live
with my phone my phone takes me
everywhere that my phone is where it
organizes my life and so that shift I
definitely live through and I recognize
that and so right now when a different
shift when it comes to artificial
intelligence and assistance and so the
way users are interacting with
technology is definitely different and
this comes Google assistant and so
Google assistant is wherever you want to
be able to give users a way to interact
with Google where they can be more
productive get things done and to enjoy
life a lot more so you can see things
like okay Google turn on some music I'm
gonna try to refrain from saying that
phrase cuz I don't want to trigger
anyone's phone so you could see that
phrase
get things done turn a little iets do
this do that be able to make it easier
for our users so Google assistant right
now we have over a million actions on
the platform we're also on over 500
million devices and so this number is
really really amazing because Google
sustained is kind of everywhere now
we're not just on phones but we're on
laptops we're on some green cars we're
on watches and the way we can interact
with users is everywhere because we want
to be supportive also we're in lots of
different languages and locales as well
so let's break this apart in regards to
what as developers can we do with Google
assistant so there's an actual physical
device which there's over 500 million
devices ah and so that is your Google
homes your Google minis your Google set
this is the machine this is the hardware
next there is Google assistant this is
Google's product where it's supportive
it's helpful it's fantastic then there's
actions on Google and that's the
platform that developers could really
shine and be able to build really
interesting things so actions on Google
is just our platform somewhere to other
platforms like Android we have of
developers who built what we call
actions on the platform to give users a
better and more rich experience as well
so for the sake of this talk I'm gonna
pretend I have a bike shop so I own a
business where it's a it's a fairly
local business and I have always wanted
to be a very healthy person in like this
alternate universe I believe there's a
Jessica there that is really active and
she writes bikes unfortunately that's
not me
so um definitely about YouTube to come
into my little world I've created where
I own a bike shop and this is kind of my
role this is an alternate life I have
and so in my bike shop I want to be able
to provide my users some really great
interaction and just to be there for
them when they need me most and so
there's different moments in times where
users might might want to interact with
my my actual business and so I was
thinking about what kind of attractions
would someone want to use if they're
thinking about a bike shop and so the
first thing I thought of
was the hours that's pretty common I
want to be able to be able to give the
ability to my users to ask what are your
hours but I want to go one step further
where it's not just so much what your
hours are but if someone's on their bike
and it's broken they want to know if it
can I come in right now that's really
the question and so I want to provide
that functionality as well where they
can ask me are you open now and I can
actually find out hey where are you can
we figure this out we also give you that
attraction give you that response and
then I also thought I have a point of
sales and in there I actually use a
firebase to store all my data and so I
have this ability to be able to know
what I haven't stocked because I want to
be able to give my users that type of
response because I know I hate when I go
to the store and they don't have the
product I'm looking for that's really
infuriating for me so I want to be able
to give my users that ability to you
know be able to figure out do they want
to come in and do it do I have the
things that they want so we're gonna
build that today
this is a very small kind of micro
Microsoft a very small project but just
to illustrate the things they could do
and we're gonna build this from scratch
so high level this is kind of what we're
working with on the left hand side the
user could say something like okay
google talk to a bike shop demo the
device here is it and what it does is it
sends the audio to who will cyst it
Google assistant will parse it out we'll
use the natural language processor we
use our knowledge graph our machine
learning ranking all the jazz to figure
out which action is the best action that
the user wants this is really really
similar so when you go to the physical
google.com and you put something into
the search bar it's really similar to
that type of technology so Google system
does that figures out okay there is a
bike shop demo that exists let me
trigger that and Google assistant will
tell the user sure here's a bike shop
demo and then now my action that I'm
building out will be able to create my
user my action will say something to the
fact of hello welcome to the bike shop
how can I help you after that the user
will be able to respond back asking for
what the hours are that again goes to
Google assistant and it should give a
response of
I'm open from 9:00 a.m. to 5:00 p.m.
Monday through Friday that's the goal
that's kind of where we're going and
these other players were working with so
first things first is let's actually
start a project on Google on actions on
Google so there we go and the power of
technology I'm actually going to be
playing a video that way we don't miss
anything up and I want to worry about my
typing and so I'm at the actions on
Google console I've just just created an
action it drops me into this really nice
um platform or this console where it has
on the left hand side set up build test
and deploy and measure and so this helps
guide us through our development over
action
we're gonna skip the setup part because
I want to go straight to you know with
the code and making sure that we finish
this in time so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go to build and I'm gonna
go to actions so I can actually build
the functionality I want and so here is
where I have a question that I'm not
really sure how I want to handle and we
have a couple options when it comes to
users requests I know for me sometimes
when I'm speaking
I don't speak the best grammar like that
sentence but generally people can
understand me and I know there's gonna
be users that are similar to me who they
might see things a little differently or
a little wonky if I want to be able to
process their information and give them
the correct feedback or correct
responses that they want so I was
thinking about a scenario that I had
drawn up in my head and I could
definitely see myself filling in
something like this I got this bike last
year on Friday
I got a flat can I come in right now and
of course for us as humans we could
parse that out and figure out like okay
what the person is really asking is that
it could come in right now but you can
imagine trying to write a regular
expression trying to pull out the dates
and times in the sense of Friday and
last year and now and trying to figure
that out and so that could be a little
messy
you won't have to deal with all that I
want to be able to have something that's
a little easier of a tool and that's
when dialogue flow comes in dialog flow
is an intent matching and entity
extraction
tool that we could use it connects
really nicely with actions on Google and
what it's gonna happen is sonic flow is
gonna do a lot of the heavy lifting for
us it's gonna grab the raw text that the
user says tries to figure out the intent
with the intent matching and pulls out
any of the entities that we've
predefined that are important that we
would like to extract from the phrases
so with dialog flow this is their
console just to give you a sneak peek
we're gonna be using this tool with our
actions on Google so let's update our
diagram now now that things have changed
a little so we've added dialogue flow
charts a diagram and now when actions on
Google gets true when it first starts it
gets triggered it's gonna trigger
dialogue flow and the welcome intent and
so now dialogue flow is gonna be
handling that response of the greeting
that we have likewise also every time
that the user speaks us Google assistant
will do the whole audio to text
transformation and then sends the text
to dialogue flow and dialogue flow will
handle the natural language processing
in regards to that that language or that
response cool so now we have that
so let's actually build this out so
let's start and actions on Google
let's connect all these together so from
here from the console we're gonna add an
action build a custom action and this
drops right into dialogue flew we're
gonna create a new agent so that's a new
agent for dialogue so I'll be connected
and we're gonna go to intents download
flow by default gives us two intents
first one is welcome so let's modify
welcome as you could see area has a
sense of events and training phrases
training phrases is what dialogue flow
will use with its machine learning to
figure out the intense components and so
by default dialogue flow gives us a lot
of great examples for training phrases
different ways of saying hello and
starting the conversation so we'll have
all those those are great and now here
with my responses I kind of want to make
some edits and make it more customized
and so I delete one so I don't what
three and this gives us the option
having three different options that our
user could hear so dialogue flow
whenever it gets trigger we'll just do a
random from these three options so my
just I had this text so they can have
the welcome to the bike shop after that
I'm gonna gonna hit save on the bottom
right hand corner you see that the tech
gets saved and that the agents training
actually starts and so it's in real time
building out the machine learning model
builds up out and on the top right hand
corner I could type in hi and we got the
response back already and so you guys
can see up here that's where he typed in
hi the user was able to get that and
then this is our response that we get
back so in doubt luckily we could test
this out but let's test this out an
actual console for actions on Google so
we go to integrations integration
settings and we're gonna click on test
let's do some continue it's gonna ask to
make sure everything's good it's
connecting everything which is awesome
and now we're dropped into the simulator
this is where in actions on Google we
could test out your actions before you
deploy and you take it out and so in
here right in the middle part right here
is a simulator on the right hand side is
different options where you could have
it where it shows the display what the
users will be seen as well as the
requests and response and any bugs as
well or errors that shows up and you can
see the logs too so really great tool so
we're gonna do talk to my test app in
here fantastic so our actions on Google
gave us back the good day welcome to the
bike shop what can I do for you today
which worked out wonderfully so that
worked out okay so now let's build out
this next intent and let me just
elaborate more on what intents our
intents are the functionality we want to
give to our users this is an option that
a user can say something so then this
action can happen this part of my bigger
action it could be invoked and so we're
gonna build out the currently open
possibility
I'm gonna go back to my video okay so
we're gonna go back into dialogue flow
to that console drink out of here go
back to intense and we're going to
create a new intense so in here we're
gonna need more intense oh I'm sorry
we're actually gonna build our hours
apologies
I got excited I'm gonna go back to my
slides we're gonna build this guy up so
sorry I'm really excited about this it's
held like this is really really awesome
so we're gonna build our hours still the
same space here we're actually gonna be
adding in our training phrases so again
this is what dialogue flow is going to
be using to be able to figure out the
intent matching and so with this
verbiage that we have you want to have
as many examples of training phrases
that users could possibly say this is a
really great time to get your UX testing
folks to get involved involved and if
you have designers when it comes to
conversation get them involved too if
you don't great thing to do is just ask
people around you how would you say this
and be able to track that so in here we
tracked it and now we're gonna add a
response so any time someone asked this
or says these type of phrases our
actions gonna respond back with we're
open Monday through Friday or we're open
from 9:00 to 9:00 to 5:00 Monday through
Friday and we're gonna hit save
fantastic the training is already happen
on the bottom right hand corner great
let's go back to our actions on Google
console and let's set this out so we're
gonna reset the simulator let's start
this by doing talk to my test app cool
that worked great and now let's type in
what are your hours
or when are you open awesome it worked
so he gave us what we're open from 9:00
to 5:00 but notice I put when are you
open and actually didn't have that in my
training phrases so again dialogue flow
was able to figure out that this was
this phrase matches the closest with the
hours intent that we had super easy
okay so now we're gonna go with the
currently open intent and so this gives
us the option for the users to be able
to ask us are you open right now so
let's build this out listen to me a
little different from the ours Mike what
we're gonna go from the beginning we
create a new intent we're gonna name it
I'm gonna use camel case because in the
my back end I'll be using javascript so
I want to be able to keep this
consistent we're gonna add some training
phrases as well so these have to do with
can I come coming can I come in now are
you open now are you currently open mind
you I'm only using a small example
because of the demo but the more free
since that you put in the better
dialogue flow is going to perform for
you cool we're gonna go down to
responses and here I don't want to give
a default response this is not going to
be truthful I can't just put your open
now or guess we are without knowing
where the user is Mabel to figure out
what time is it the day so here I
actually deleted the response and I'm
gonna go down to fulfillment and I'm
gonna enable the webhook that way when
this intent gets called it's gonna go to
my fulfillment and hit save
fantastic normally we test it but my
fulfillments my back-end and we even
built that out yet so we have this
possibility but we haven't connected all
the way so I'm gonna put a pin in that
and we're gonna keep going and we're
gonna build out the intent of tire stock
this is the idea that people can ask me
do you have this type of tire that way
if they're writing their bike and they
plug their phone they're talking to my
action cuz their bike just broke they
could ask me in real time do you have
something now I want to give that
functionality to them so let's fill that
part out
fantastic similarly when it create a new
intent I'm gonna call this tire stop
and I want to give it some training
phrases so I put in my mountain bike but
I kind of feel like I'm missing
something here I kind of want to be able
to know what type of tire I'm using or
what tire my user wants to get so if you
double click your system and entities
that exist in dialogue flow so dialogue
flow understands this idea of time
measurements common names as well and so
there's nothing like a tire type when it
comes to entities with dialogue flow
that's kind of a special niche thing
that only Mike my company or my business
does so what I'm gonna do instead is I
want to make my own so let's cancel this
intent and let's go to entities in here
I could build out my own custom entities
so this entity I'm going to call a tire
type this is the idea of a tire type and
in here I'm gonna be able to predefined
you know there's this idea of a Mountain
tire which you can also use the actual
measurement of 27.5 times two point one
or two point zero our cost crunching
country and so what's gonna happen here
is all these synonyms that I'm providing
to dialog flow if a user uses that it
knows oh the user means Mountain and so
it's gonna reduce about to Mountain and
in my back-end I'm only having to handle
this idea of Mountain similarly with
with returning terrain if someone says
Racing or use as a measurement of three
seven hundred times twenty-three it's
going to just reduce down to Road
terrain and so again my back-end I don't
have to worry about this one variable or
this one possible value for the tire
type entity that we're creating so I've
made all those fantastic I'm gonna go
back to my intense and let's build this
out again
so again tire stocked and now here what
the training phrases I'm gonna type in
my mouth something affecting my mountain
bike for some reason mountain is a
really challenging word for me to spell
I know right you have no idea how many
times I recorded this this is why I
didn't want to
so my tire on my mountain bike god fly
do you have tires and here I could click
on that and now I could identify it as a
tire type so now dialogue flow knows oh
this is a thing I need to keep track of
and give to the developer on the packet
and now when I did that BMX one it
automatically did that for me
so now dialogue flow has learned that
this is information that I really want
to keep and keep track of my juice there
are times where you know numbers is a
system in and in entity and so I just
have to help dialog flow a little bit by
going up this whole thing is a tire type
so we just give it super easy super nice
I heard someone say sweet that's awesome
right Davao is amazing so with this I'm
going to say that this is required I
need this for my intent to be triggered
and if someone just says do you have
tires I could ask them automatically
what type of wake that way I'm not
having to handle that back and forth but
dialogue flow will for me cool made that
again I don't want to do an automatic
response I want to be able to figure
this out dynamically somebody enable my
fulfillment and it's safe cool fantastic
so we have these three intents built out
that we customized and now next thing we
want to do is we will actually want to
build the web hook we want build it
we're after dialogue flow has been
triggered it goes and we can handle this
data actions on Google we have a client
library written a no js' and this is
just an example of what the hours intent
would look like if we didn't
automatically program that in where it
was our Mike responded by dialogue flow
this is what it would look like what I
really enjoy about this is that you just
make an instance of dialogue flow set it
to app and now you could just do dot
intent passing in the title or the name
of your intent and dialogue flow which
for this example would be hours passes
in the conversation object and then in
my function itself
I do convo comes that ask
pass on a string super super simple this
is kind of the basic thing that you can
do there's a lot more really fun things
they could do in addition we'll get to
that later so let's fill this out
let's filled out the currently open
intent cool so I forgot to mention I'm
gonna go back here you never want to
start things from scratch
so um on our github repo we do have a
dialog flow web hook template for our
nodejs that will have some boilerplate
code and that's what we're gonna be
starting off with okay so this is the
code that were Amy's tearing off what it
has by default which is really great the
Welcome intent that's aa phlox dialog
flow against us so here we're gonna just
edit that to be written for our
currently open so here a big note if
it's not spelled the same as camelcase
cents or kept capitalization sensitive
he's sensitive your intent name has to
match with this strain so what we're
doing is we're gonna check to see if
it's currently open and then we're gonna
pass in the string that we're currently
open now we close at 5:00 p.m. with the
Comcast and then if it's not currently
open we'll let our user know so we're
currently no we're currently closed but
we open every weekday that way depending
on whatever time it is my user will be
able to take out the appropriate
response so I also have to build out the
actual function of currently open this
checks to make sure that the timestamp
or the date time is is correct I'm also
making it law assumptions that this
person is in California because I only
have one shop I'm not international yet
but there are ways to be able to get
information from the user of where
location they're at a rough location so
you can ask for that permission as well
that way you could have that and then
able to track to see what of your stores
is the closest one to the users location
so cool so we built that out this is the
Kobe I guess when we saw me you write it
so let's move on to the next one so
let's connect this let's try this out
we've written our intent now we've
written there was the fulfillment for
that intent let's deploy this seeing the
way the client library is built server
list sounds like a really great option I
don't need a lot of that overhead and so
something that we really enjoy is again
we don't need all that infrastructure
because we only are using that app Don
intent and then also what's really great
is that we're not paying for we're not
using it so let's say if I build like
the next great application and it goes
off it's on Google system is on over 500
million devices my action will be able
to scale really easily with that as well
so we choose to use serverless and we're
gonna be using anything cloud functions
because when dialogue flow receives the
raw tax parses it out fill it figures
out the intent it will trigger to our
Google Cloud function which are trigger
our actual back in a response as well
and again what's really nice it's in
nodejs so you know this kind of all fits
really great together
so let me let's update our image so from
dialog flow when it comes after the
Welcome intent because the Wileman chat
will be automatic at this point so when
it's on the what are your hours dollar
flow will do the parsing plan any
entities it needs and it's gonna trigger
my cloud functions cool so let's build
that out we're going to just go to here
to the firebase is getting started and
we'll grab all the tools that we need
so we'll NPM all of the firebase tools
it's a great time to take a water break
download everything all the magic I'm
always worried that's gonna take too
long but didn't that's great cool we did
that pretty much scroll down a little
bit
what didn't you just make sure I'm
logged in I already know I've already
logged in I know it will do the firebase
in it functions run that command well
that's gonna be doing is it's going to
build everything out and send ask me
which project to use I'm going to use my
bike shop demo I know that I'm using
javascript drive all myself to be
enforced yes so I want everything be
overwritten yes please and install all
the dependencies I need so that's gonna
take a couple seconds that's you long
cool soon the magic fantastic
now that's all completed in there now
the next thing they do is just a deploy
find the command so firebase deploy - -
only functions we have the CD into our
functions directory go in there that's
it a good note
make sure you do that if you don't want
work so you see the interface functions
directory then you run the command does
all the jazz add and from here it's
gonna give you a URL from that URL
you're going to be able to access the
actual URL that's gonna be live to give
to your back-end so in firebase you're
gonna grab that URL from the functions
option that was a little fast so let's
do this again cool grab that URL
you're gonna go dialogue flow and in
dialogue flow we're gonna go down to
fulfillments and in fulfilment we're
going in able the web hook able that
that's gonna give us a spot where we can
put in our URL so if you decide not to
use firebase you use won't use something
else that's where you would be adding
your own web hook URL and then in here
we're gonna scroll down hit save and
this will connect everything together
cool so now we're gonna go to our
actions on Google
let's talk to my test app fantastic so
well the default welcome is gonna happen
gives us a little customized with the
greeting we're gonna Asif we're
currently open
and we are we're currently open it is
before 5:00 so fantastic that works ok
so now I want to connect this to my
database I want to be able to have it
where I could do they intent to make
sure I have all my socks I currently
already have everything stored in my
club fire store for those who are not
familiar with it it's a no SQL database
and it's synchronous and conflict for a
solution in real time which is nice
because I'm gonna be you know things
might happen people might be coming in
stocking up things get bought I won't be
able to have this where it's in real
time so in order to connect firestore to
our action we just need to add in those
these four lines pulling the firebases
admin also fire basis functions and then
also initializing it and create our
database cool and now let's build out
our fire stock intents tire stock intent
cool okay so we need get it and we just
want to show you my databases what it
looks like this might be a Mac spikes
that I have and everything that's in
stock so you can see what I have I'm not
in stocked with everything and I have
quantities as well so that's how my
database looks like so in here let's add
in those four lines of code that we need
it fantastic and those are building out
that intent and so what's happening here
is we have our tire stock intent we're
gonna be grabbing the parameters and so
this one's a little different we're on
line 37 we're passing in the
conversation object and primps and so
this is an additional argument that we
got that we could gap the parameters and
the entities that dialogue flow gives us
and so on line 38 you see pram stock
tire tire types we make that into our
own variable so now we could grab what
dialogue flow is giving us in regards to
the tire type so it's only giving us
four options which is great then we're
going to be calling for our database
passing in that tire type and making
sure to see hey do I even have this tire
type in
stock is it something I even have
documentation on if I don't we could
tell them sorry we do not carry this and
if we do and it's in stock we tell them
yes we have it and if it's not in stock
we say sorry we're currently out of
stock and then of course we want to make
sure there's any errors we capture that
so that way we could log our own errors
if something weird happens okay so let's
try this out we already deployed it and
then we're gonna talk to our action cool
gives us a different greeting and now
we're going to ask you have a BMX tires
and stock cool we have it and it's in
stock
okay so let's test out the other ones
just in case because I don't have
everything in stock so do you carry
psycrow cross tires that's how much of a
bike person I am cyclocross well we're
sorry we're currently out of stock so we
don't have that and then my favorite one
can I get mountain tires we have it and
it's in stock cool okay so there's the
code that we wrote out for for that
intense and so now let's update our
graph just to make sure that we're all
on the same page so now that we have our
cloud functions and now that from crop
function we could trigger and get
information from our fire base our fire
stored database and so this is our
updated image and then here we go after
that this is my actual action what we
would want to do before we deploy want
to show everything to the completion is
you're gonna want to go back up to setup
an invocation you're gonna want to add
in the invocation name the invocation
name is the actual name that we're gonna
be giving Google that it's going to use
that users can trigger and so for this
one I'm most likely gonna want to use
like Jessica's bike shop or my bike shop
demo because I really don't want people
just to accidentally trigger it you'd be
putting the information in there as well
as well as picking out to see what type
of voice you would like and then once
you submit all of that we've already
tested it we can go to deploy and in
here you'd want to add a description
because we do have a directory so you
add in your description your images and
example invocations the details of your
company another thing is you're going to
need a privacy policy as well so you
input all of this great information as
well as the rest of location targeting
so what countries you want to target
your surface capabilities so there's
times where you might build an action
that is not its aim or can only be used
with images or like a visual interface
as well and so you want to be able to
note that that way it's not trickable
on things that are does not have any
visual elements so something like a
Google home and so you'd be able to put
the information in there too and then
also you could after that we're gonna
want to release it and so we've
introduced at Google i/o alpha and beta
releases as well so with alpha you could
might list about 20 emails an account so
that way you could test this out making
sure it works with a beta you could
submit but you need to have your privacy
policy with this and it goes through
approval process with alpha you do not
have to get approved because it's only
for xx and with beta you can have it for
200 people and then you could do the
regular for production as well and so we
would do that and that is my bike shop
so high level this is what we did from
end to end the conversation goes up and
around so from the user potentially all
the way to our database and then all the
way back so just another image for those
folks
taking a moment cuz there's photos
happening just if you want no yeah cool
okay so one of the big questions I get
is like oh great just to go that's
that's awesome you built a thing and
it's really nifty but like how do people
know about these things how do we tell
our customers cuz that's really what we
want so a couple ways just so that
people know the way that you could
trigger this explicitly is by going okay
okay so and so talk to the name of the
action and so our a canonical example
that we use is personal chef and so
we're just telling Google I want to talk
to this action you can also do something
where you could bypass the Welcome and
go straight into the interactivity that
you want and so an example is okay
Google a personal chef for a hot soup
recipe and so for the demo that I filled
out it would be something like okay ah
ask my bike demo if mountain bike tires
aren't stuck that way bypasses the
welcome and all that Jess so our users
are getting really great interactivity
and getting to what they want to get
done earlier and faster another way of
being able to get your actions triggered
is implicit triggering this has to deal
with just asking Google I want to do a
thing like this and so this is really
this gets really similar to when you
just go to our website and you type
something in it gives you the best
results based off of some really great
algorithms and it will try to surface
the action that Google thinks is best
for the user at that time so here are
some examples of implicit triggering we
also have a directory so when I
mentioned earlier you want to put in all
great information so we do have a
directory where I know I love to go in
there and just check out what other
people are doing see see what's going on
so there's that and then this one I
think is the most like impactful way to
communicate is action links and so you
could link your action from anywhere and
so let's say you have a social media
campaign that you're building now and
you want to highlight that you spent all
this time
building this action you can actually
have a URL that you could post on
Twitter or any other social media
platform and send your users straight to
the action itself so that's another
capability to so here's a list of all
resources that way you have everything
you need at photos please like to put
this at the end that way I believe
almost everything I mentioned here's a
great starting point for it all our
resources on there of course we have our
own code labs and samples things exist
out there something I did really gloss
over completely was design when it comes
to building your action we have a lot of
great rich design documentation I know
when I was building my first action as a
developer I saw design and all that skip
skip skip skip that bite me and the
trishy leader that was not a good idea
so please learn from me and be better
than me really check out the
documentation when it comes to design
because there are many times where
you're building this out and it you
could get lost in the conversation and
where you're at in the conversation flow
or what type of phrases people might use
so I definitely highly recommend go to
the design Docs write out the physical
conversations people might be having and
using that as your template versus just
trying to live code it we have really we
have great documentation in regards to
that we even have a code lab just
designed for designing your action as
well so that's not this is a way that
you could stay connected if you're
interested on actions on Google figuring
out being part of the cool kids club and
building your own action so we're active
on Google+ and of course our developers
page and then on Twitter if you build
anything out I would love to know what
you've done you could use the hashtag
aog does that's something that we are
usually checking out just to see what
people are building then there's my
contact information down there thank you
appreciate it
[Applause]
you
[Music]